[Music]
a lot of art from the middle ages is so
bizarre it seems beyond explanation
which is why it's no surprise that these
seemingly nonsensical images have become
popular sources of memes in recent years
it's hard not to look at these visuals
and ask yourself wait what is going on
here so for this entry into the archive
i'll try to track down the real meaning
behind some of these images which have
circulated on the internet without
context but keep in mind that what i've
found in my research is that for many
illustrations medieval art historians
are just as clueless as the rest of us
with that said let's begin to start we
have the curious trend of medieval
babies who look a little off the sheer
amount of unfortunate looking babies in
medieval and later renaissance art
suggests more is going on than just a
few misplaced brushstrokes portraits of
medieval infants seem like they were
intentionally styled to look like tiny
middle-aged men and indeed that is more
or less what's going on here these
artists are following the trend of the
homunculus which translates to little
man in latin the idea behind the
homunculus is related to the baby jesus
who was the most popular infant to paint
at the time due to a very literal
interpretation of the church's idea that
jesus was born fully formed and
unchanged a lot of classic religious art
from the era has a very adult face to
jesus and paintings of other infants
started to follow this trend as well
hence babies being painted with receding
hairlines and layers of muscle by the
time renaissance styles developed over
more of europe however the somewhat
unsettling trend of adult-faced infants
went out of practice and frescoes
thankfully started featuring much more
normal looking babies
switching topics another unusual theme
in medieval art that the internet has
picked up on is that in scenes of people
meeting their untimely demise which
should be pretty grim the sufferers seem
strangely laid back seriously all of
these people seem pretty chill about
their imminent death all things
considered in fact a lot of them appear
somewhat bored or at most subtly annoyed
by the situation which is an unusual
reaction to such a serious event so why
are there entire battle scenes where
everyone seems completely checked out
well one explanation is that the neutral
expressions come from the cultural value
of greeting death with a calmness so
you'll be rewarded in what comes after
while staying calm and grounded can be
healthy i will say i think some of these
people might be taking their chillness a
little too far
and while we're on the subject of
strange portrayals of death death itself
as personified by skeletal figures
coming to haunt the living often looked
a little goofier than one might expect
which has led to a variety of jokes
online most of these illustrations are
actually related to the concept of the
dance macabre or dance of death the
dance macabre was a concept that death
was an equalizer coming for all classes
of feudal society the images were
designed to remind people to see this
life's fleeting nature and to embrace
death when the time came a related and
also strangely amusing image that has
become popular online is this portrait
of three individuals having a bizarre
reaction to a group of skeletons the
image is actually based on a legend
called the three living and the three
dead in which three nobles encounter
three skeletons who are actually undead
reflections of the nobles sent to
frighten them into changing their
immoral ways it's a pretty unique tale
with a lot of variations and one which
shows up a fair amount to medieval art
moving on one particularly strange trend
in medieval art that has captured some
attention online is how some artists
depicted rabbits various manuscripts
portray rabbits not as we know them as
small fuzzy animals that aren't much of
a threat to a human but as large
threatening creatures carrying off
helpless villagers it's a concept that
certainly stands out in the margins of
illuminated texts so what is going on
here are these some kind of mythical
beasts did rabbits have some kind of
attitude problem in the middle ages well
the most accepted theory is that these
strange hilarious images are meant to be
just that jokes just like how we share
funny images today this sort of bizarre
art was probably something medieval
monks had to laugh about with their
friends and yes this trend is somewhat
similar to monty python's famous deadly
rabbit's got a vicious
briefly leaving the medieval era for a
series of portraits i felt i had to
include we have the highly unusual 18th
century self-portraits of french painter
joseph de croix although trained in the
classical style the successful decroy
became unsatisfied with the constraints
of traditional portraiture which at the
time were almost entirely serious with
somber body language and reserved
compositions so decroy started creating
art with absurd larger than life
expressions that really go against the
standards of the time in breaking these
constraints his works actually resemble
the earlier 16th and 17th century style
of portraiture called trones which were
paintings like the one you see before
you that frequently featured exaggerated
facial expressions some of these
expressions are so unusual that it might
seem hard to believe they aren't modern
parodies but despite what most classical
portraits might lead you to believe some
people from the past had a very modern
sense of humor and decroy was certainly
one of those people today his most
famous image is probably this one where
he painted himself pointing at viewers
and laughing at them it says something
that this image is still funny to people
on the internet hundreds of years after
it was painted before we reach our final
topic there are a few other
miscellaneous drawings i'd like to try
and address first we have this amusing
illustration of what seems to be a
mythical bird monster carrying a smaller
creature and a human away on its back
and the two passengers appear so deep in
argument they haven't noticed their
being hoisted away despite appearances
this isn't a medieval illustration but a
depiction of a costumed individual at a
17th century fair with the figures on
their back likely some kind of puppets
pretty unusual next we have this image
of a man who seems like he's being
wrapped up in a sheet by his friends
despite the goofy vibe this image is
likely vitalis of milan a saint who
according to legend was sentenced to
death so those two aren't his friends
but his executioners and all likelihood
lowering him into his grave and finally
on a lighter note we've got this
famously weird portrait of a baby and no
this isn't one of those bizarre medieval
era portraits but a stylized portrait by
the 20th and 21st century figurative
artist fernando botero whose unique
style sometimes causes people to assume
his work was painted centuries prior
and closing out this entry into the
archive we have a topic i've touched on
in the past but is always worth
revisiting that being the bizarre
medieval trend of depicting knight's
fighting snails you can find these
bizarre showdowns hidden within the
margins of many manuscripts there's a
strangeness here that is pretty apparent
i mean snails don't seem like the most
obvious creatures to depict as
gargantuan menacing juggernauts and
maybe i'm over analyzing but to me
there's a sense in these images that the
knights might not make it these snails
seem like they mean business and this
wasn't a one-off concept we have over 65
documented images of snails doing battle
with various warriors and what's most
intriguing is that we're not totally
sure why with theories ranging from the
snails representing class divisions to
being a joke about the concept of a
knight's armor to a metaphoric
personification of the slow and steady
approach of death or maybe this is just
another example of medieval artists
trying to create something to make their
friends laugh just like what we do
online today
and that's all the weird medieval art we
have time for in this century i made
other videos covering unusual medieval
depictions of animals and mythical
creatures that explain additional
bizarre illustrations i didn't get to
hear thank you for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support and like subscribe and hit the
notification icon to stay up to date on
all things curious see you in the next
video
[Music]